two jokers three greek weddings and how
many spider-men these upcoming sequels
have a lot to keep track of warning this
video contains fast flashing images
viewer discretion is advised especially
for those with photosensitive epilepsy
roger ebert hailed the original this is
spinal tap as one of the funniest movies
ever made
the 1984 mockumentary tells the story of
fading band spinal tap desperately
searching for musical glory in a world
that's forgotten them
and the whole time they're being filmed
by the not so talented documentarian
marty debergie played by the film's
actual director rob reiner with it's so
terrible their amazing songs and its
improvised jokes it's no wonder spinal
tap became an instant classic now reiner
is getting the band back together
original stars michael mckeon
christopher guest and harry shearer will
be picking up their guitars and rocking
around stonehenge in the film's upcoming
sequel scheduled for release in 2024
right in time for the original's 40th
anniversary reiner will return as both
the film's director and de berkey
but it's very very special because if
you can see yeah the numbers all go to
11.
here's hoping they can turn this sequel
up to 11.
valic is back baby the demonic nun who's
been haunting the conjuring universe
ever since the second film in the
franchise is getting her very own sequel
the nun terrorized audiences back in
2018 scaring up a whopping 365 million
dollars across the globe and whether
you're a hollywood producer or a
malignant evil entity money talks
speaking of malignant akilah cooper the
screenwriter behind james wan's
absolutely bonkers 2021 thriller is
going to pen the script for the nun too
if she can bring the same wild energy to
valley's tale that she brought to
gabriel's then this next installment in
the conjuring franchise will be
something special indeed there's no word
yet on the plot or release date but
we're waiting with baited terrified
breath the conjuring the devil made me
do it director michael shaves will helm
the sequel which will take place in
1950s france and see sister irene face
off with balik bonnie ahrens is set to
reprise her role as the demonic villain
and according to collider taissa farmiga
will be back as sister irene 2019's
joker takes a daring new approach to
batman's most famous adversary as
inspired by gritty 70's cinema as it is
by comic books joaquin phoenix plays
arthur fleck a troubled wannabe comedian
who suffers an emotional breakdown on
the way to becoming the clownish
supervillain phoenix won an academy
award for his performance and joker
earned more than 1 billion dollars at
the box office clearly there's
significant demand for additional movies
about the joker's rise to infamy
according to the hollywood reporter
director todd phillips discussed
tackling more dc comics movies mere days
after joker debuted in june 2022 philip
cemented rumors of a sequel when he
posted a photo of the next joker script
to instagram the snapshot revealed that
the film will be titled joker folia do
folia do is a psychological term
referring to a delusion shared by
multiple people which might suggest a
team-up the introduction of other
villains or a city-wide revolt pop star
turned oscar-nominated actor lady gaga
is slated to play harley quinn in the
film which is rumored to be a musical
according to variety it will dance its
way into theaters on october 4th 2024
a dazzlingly original film full of humor
action comic book theatrics and heart
2018's spider-man into the spider-verse
earned 375 million dollars at the global
box office took home an academy award
for best animated feature and became one
of the most critically acclaimed
superhero movies ever made all that plus
an endlessly repeatable premise miles
morales travels through the multiverse
and meets other spider beings made a
sequel very likely a follow-up was
officially announced in november 2019
with christopher miller and phil lord
returning to the writing team along with
the new director joachim dos santos and
screenwriter david callahan kemp powers
and justin k thompson will join dos
santos as co-directors the upcoming
sequel will examine miles morales and
gwen stacy's growing relationship which
will deepen from friendship into romance
in june 2022 sony pictures animation's
twitter account announced they and the
film's other heroes will face the spot
voiced by jason schwartzman this
interdimensional baddie is able to
sprint through the multiverse at
incredible speed spider-man across the
spider verse was initially set to hit
theaters in april 2022 but sony pushed
the release to june 2nd 2023 and split
the film in two the third installment
spider-man beyond the spider-verse
arrives on march 29 2024
in 2002 my big fat greek wedding was a
massive unexpected pop culture
phenomenon the flick began as nia
vardalos semi-autobiographical one-woman
show which became a surprising hit
the more bizarre it is in the movie the
more likely it is to be actually pulled
from my true life
actor and producer rita wilson loved it
and soon enough so did her husband tom
hanks a few years later they co-produced
the film adaptation which was quietly
released in april 2002 it became a
blockbuster that grossed 368 million
dollars worldwide making it the highest
earning romantic comedy of all time my
big fat greek wedding led to cbs sitcom
my big fat greek life and a movie sequel
my big fat greek wedding too
he's looking act like we're having fun
one two three
in june 2022
vardalos announced on instagram that
filming had wrapped on location in
greece for my big fat greek wedding 3.
she'll be directing as well as reprising
the role of tula portacolos according to
us weekly other original cast members
have been seen around set including john
corbett elena camporis andrea martin
lewis mandalore and maria vikrazis
a third sequel to ghostbusters the 1984
mega hit starring comedy icons dan
aykroyd bill murray harold ramis and
rick moranis has been on the table for
decades according to esquire and tour
ackeroyd had ambitious plans but they
never panned out instead fans got a
reboot with 2016's ghostbusters which
features a whole new set of spirit
trapping scientists played by kristen
wiig kate mckinnon leslie jones and
melissa mccarthy that film's middling
box office returns and just okay
critical reviews ensured any sequels to
its take never came to pass and so sony
rebooted ghostbusters once more with
2021's ghostbusters afterlife set in the
world of the original two ghostbusters
films with cameos from living cast
members and appearances from characters
like egon spangler's daughter and
grandchildren the film was a hit at the
relatively subdued covedera box office
prompting sony to order a sequel jason
reitman director of ghostbusters
afterlife and son of original
ghostbusters helmer ivan reitman will
return to direct as the end sequence of
ghostbusters afterlife suggests the film
will take place in new york city just
like the 80s ghostbusters films and is
set to release december 20th 2023
with a roughly 200 million dollar price
tag the gray man is one of the most
expensive movies netflix has ever made
the streaming-only title boasts an
all-star cast in chris evans anna de
armas and ryan gosling gosling anchors
the action thriller as 6 an elite cia
operative who runs for his life after
revealing highly classified state
secrets
you hurt
i mean my ego's a little bruised netflix
hadn't released viewership numbers for
the film's opening weekend when it
announced the sequel gosling and
directors joe and anthony russo will
return for the second film though
screenwriters stephen mcfeely and
christopher marcus shared writing duties
with joe russo for the first movie
mcfeely will go it alone for the second
a grey man spin-off is also in the works
with deadpool and zombieland writers
rhett reese and paul wernick taking a
crack at the screenplay
2021's nobody stars unlikely action hero
bob odenkirk best known for his
performance as saul goodman on better
call saul and breaking bad as seemingly
unassuming dad hutch mansell when his
mundane life is upended by russian
mobsters hutch must revisit the skills
he cultivated as an assassin nobody was
a rare hit of the kovid 19 era in august
2022 director david leach told collider
another film was in the works everyone
involved is like full steam ahead we are
in the script process the studio loved
the results and it's happening as fast
as we can make it happen
while hocus pocus failed to make much of
a splash when it was first released in
1993 it has since become a halloween
staple with new fans discovering the
witchy wackiness of the sanderson
sisters each year the film follows a
group of kids who accidentally resurrect
the three sisters who were executed in
1693 thrilled to be back the sisters set
about to suck away the soul of every
child in salem to stay alive unless the
children who resurrected them plus an
enchanted cat can stop them original
hocus pocus stars bette midler kathy
najimi and sarah jessica parker are back
for the sequel and seeking revenge also
making an appearance in hocus pocus 2
are doug jones of the shape of water
hannah wattingham of ted lasso and sam
richardson of beep with a script by jen
diangelo hocus pocus 2 will be directed
by ann fletcher prepare for all sorts of
witchy fun on disney plus on september
30th 2022
the original clerks released in 1994
follows a pair of jaded pop culture
obsessed friends who work in a new
jersey grocery and video store
respectively shot for just 27
575 dollars and paid for with writer
director kevin smith's credit cards the
film became a cult classic it launched
smith's career as one of the preeminent
filmmakers of his generation and master
of the view-esque universe of
interconnected movies which includes
mall rats dogma jay and silent bob
strike back and clerks 2 the 2006 sequel
which finds the characters suffering
through low paying low status jobs at a
fast food restaurant smith suffered a
heart attack in 2019 grappling with
issues of life death and legacy inspired
him to write clerks 3 which will tell
his own story through the film's
characters it goes like this after
nearly dying of a heart attack randall
teams up with fellow clerk dante to make
a low-budget indie movie about their
lives called clerks i'm living on
borrowed time no more watching movies
i'm gonna make a movie
the first trailer for clerks 3 hit the
internet in july 2022 featuring
returning cast members and frequent
smith collaborators jason muse rosario
dawson and justin long the film will hit
theaters via special event screenings
running from september 13 2022 to
september 18 2022.
that's how we did it in the 90s son
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]